>> Harris: THIS IS NOT
MARCH 2020.
THAT’S A QUOTE, A MESSAGE FROM A
GEORGIA MOM WHO WENT AFTER HER
SCHOOL BOARD FOR STILL REQUIRING
CHILDREN, YOUNG KIDS TO MASK UP
AND SOCIALLY DISTANCE.
SHE SAID THERE IS LITTLE
EVIDENCE KIDS ARE AT RISK OF
GETTING COVID.
HER OUTRAGE IS GOING VIRAL.
>> EVERY MONTH I COME HERE AND I
HEAR THE SAME THING,
SOCIAL-EMOTIONAL HEALTH.
IF YOU TRULY MEAN THAT YOU WOULD
END THE MASK REQUIREMENT TONIGHT
TONIGHT.
THIS IS NOT MARCH 2020 ANYMORE,
WE HAVE THREE VACCINES, EVERY
ADULT IN THE STATE OF GEORGIA
THAT WANTS A VACCINE IS ELIGIBLE
TO GET IT RIGHT NOW AND EVERYONE
OF US KNOWS THAT YOUNG CHILDREN
ARE NOT AFFECTED BY THIS VIRUS.
THEY ARE NOT AND THAT IS A
BLESSING BUT AS THE ADULTS, WHAT
HAVE WE DONE WITH THAT BLESSING?
WE’VE SHOVED IT TO THE SIDE AND
SAID WE DON’T CARE, YOU ARE
STILL GOING TO WEAR A MASK ON
YOUR FACE EVERY DAY, FIVE AND
6-YEAR-OLDS.
YOU STILL CAN PLAY TOGETHER ON
THE PLAYGROUND LIKE NORMAL
CHILDREN, SEVEN AND 8-YEAR-OLDS
RAID WE DON’T CARE, WE ARE STILL
GOING TO FORCE YOU TO CARRY A
BURDEN THAT WAS NEVER YOURS TO
CARRY.
SHAME ON US.
MY 6-YEAR-OLD LOOKS AT ME EVERY
MONTH BEFORE I COME HERE AND
SAYS "ARE YOU GOING TO TELL THEM
TONIGHT, TELL THEM I DON’T WANT
TO WEAR THIS ANYMORE."
AND I SAY BABY, IT’S NOT TIME TO
FIGHT THAT BATTLE YET.
I TRY TO EXPLAIN IT.
IT’S APRIL 15TH, 2021 AND IT’S
TIME, TAKE THESE MASKS OFF OF MY
CHILD.
>> Harris: KAYLEIGH McENANY,
IT IS VISCERAL WHEN YOU WATCH
THAT.
YOUR FIRST REACTION?
>> Kayleigh: IT REMINDS ME OF
THE MOMENT DR. SCOTT ATLAS
WALKED INTO MY OFFICE AND SAID
"WHAT CIVILIZATION CIVILIZATION
THEIR CHILDREN?"
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU HAVE AN
EXPERT FROM OXFORD, HARVARD AND
STANFORD ALL TALKING ABOUT MASKS
WITH CHILDREN CITING DATA,
STUDIES FROM ICELAND AND SWEDEN
SAYING THIS IS NOT NECESSARY,
IT’S REMOVED FROM YOUTUBE.
WE SACRIFICED OUR CHILDREN AND
WHEN THE SCIENCE IS ON THE SIDE
OF REOPENING SCHOOLS, NOT
WEARING MASKS IF YOU ARE UNDER
FIVE, WE SACRIFICED OUR